the President of the United States
picked a fight with you on Twitter
randomly Chrissy Teigen opens up about
her Twitter fight with the President of
the United States we all just wait for
our day to come yeah and mine happen to
be Sunday the 33 year old stopped by The
Ellen DeGeneres Show where the top
quickly turned to her recent
back-and-forth with Donald Trump my
heart stopped because at that moment you
know that you're about to get oh just a
whoop the wide explain people explain
what happened though
like weird feeling I was really angry I
think my eyes filled up with water just
at the shock of it that I can't believe
this really happens right now
in case you missed it here's what went
down between Chrissy and the Donald
Chrissy's hubby John Legend was featured
in an MSNBC interview about criminal
justice reform pay attention to those
things and then if you want to get
involved some more get involved with
free America my organization or any
other organization in your community
that's when the president hopped on his
go-to social media platform to deliver a
lengthy series of tweets about not
getting enough credit for the passage of
criminal justice reform legislation
writing in part now that it is past
people that had virtually nothing to do
with it are taking the praise guys like
boring musician John Legend and his
filthy mouth wife are talking now about
how great it is but I didn't see them
around when we needed help getting it
passed yeah you heard that right
he said filthy mouth wife and boring so
what did Chrissy think of trumps insults
well she said he wasn't wrong those two
things are true John is before I do have
a filthy mouth she also explained that
ironically she didn't even know John was
in the special I didn't even know he was
filming this thing on a Saturday I know
anything about it
and even though Chrissy says she was
totally shook at first she admits the
feud isn't all that surprising I mean
this wasn't that random I've said a lot
of things in the past I think since live
2012
things about him Chrissy was previously
blocked by the President on Twitter it's
ridiculous all because of Twitter so
she actually found out about the tweets
when friends sent her screenshots when
the card lands on you that day it's just
really like a wrap because your whole
night's ruined we spent the entire rest
of the night just sitting just like this
next to each other handing each other
our phone should I say this show you say
this no Tracy this no no it has to be
funnier no no cuz we're mad yeah we're
mad well cover your ears kids because
Chris he ended up calling the leader of
the free world a get bit in her response
and the not-safe-for-work phrase ended
up trending on twitter we're still
working on how to copyright it and while
it may not seem like it based off
Chrissy's a most recent Twitter exchange
she insists she's been making an effort
to clean up her act online I've really
I've gotten to this point where I don't
want to offend people just for a joke of
course
et will be here to bring you all of the
latest news from Chrissy Teigen so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]